when I said there are no adults in a
room I didn't just mean us I meant in
the world it's like I expected other
people to be adults oh wait they're also
all children it's like I knew I was a
kid I know my friends were kids we're
trying to move from kid to adult that's
like we knew this is our us moving from
kid to adult but then we noticed wait
where are the adults once we started to
understand how the world works and like
how other things work and how people do
things and like why they don't do things
and such and they're like oh oh
interested oh you can't do X and then
like why can't we do it so if was
possible someone would have already done
and they were like has someone tried it
and they're like I don't know surely
someone has and then we tried and we'd
work because it's just so unbelievably
much about what people tell themselves
as possibility is impossible it's just
completely fake like the market isn't
efficient like the efficient American
hypothesis is just wrong it's just not
true of reality